hi there hi there this is Steve Kaufman
I'm going to talk a little bit about
something that relates to language and
it relates to education but it's a
little bit different from the straight
language learning and I've been talking
about and it relates to what is known as
critical thinking and I have been on
this email exchange listserv forum where
people who are involved in ESL teaching
and helping immigrants and so forth have
been discussing what they call I think
there were several subjects one was
critical thinking beginning ESL class um
I think they were talking a little bit
about the use of technology in the
classroom I guess got into a lot of
different subjects but the critical
thinking I have the impression that
people who teach language to immigrants
or low literacy learners think that they
are going to teach them how to think and
I have been struggling with this and I
just cannot see how you do that I think
that you can help people reason you can
help people first of all you have to
help them improve their language if
they're gonna speak intelligently in a
language need a lot of words so the
first part of it before you even worry
about helping them learn how to think to
my mind has to be to get them to acquire
a lot of words I mean it depends what
they're gonna talk about if they're
gonna talk about things that are very
basic and simple then they don't need a
lot of words but again it depends on
their goals but I think words getting
some natural expressions in the language
is number one you shouldn't mess with
their thinking at that stage and then
you can help
with some formulas for organizing their
thoughts so that they become a little
more persuasive at least persuasive in
terms of the culture of the language
you're teaching so that in the case of
English we would suggest to them that
they express their views this way that
they support their arguments this way
because that's more persuasive to an
english-speaking listener I suppose if
you are learning Spanish or Chinese then
there would be arranged a different
range of ways of expressing your views
that that are considered persuasive and
so you really learn how to apply some
form of logic to justify the position
that you have because most people arrive
at a position on certain subjects based
more on emotion then on logic few people
sit back and sort of have a blank slate
and say now what do I really think about
you know whatever global warming
starting from nothing from no influence
from family from anything just like I'm
gonna deduce a position you know that
just doesn't happen and the proof is
that that people you know very
well-educated people at least in terms
of our book learning type of education
it can have tremendously different views
on something so and which is a good
thing
I mean people should have different
views that means that they have all used
logic to defend whatever position they
arrived at and the more logical you are
the better you are using arguments and
appearing to analyze and synthesize and
investigate and observe and perhaps look
at two sides of the coin
all of this makes you more persuasive
but if the idea and I on this email
exchange that I'm on it's a lot of
teachers and they're all talking about
wonderful projects that they've been on
and encouraging their learners to be
open minded and question their role in
society and who has
our and society and and of course really
what they're doing is they're forcing
their sort of activist agenda whether it
be women's issues or the power of the
powerless or whatever they're trying to
kind of inculcate these activist views
into their students who really only want
to learn English and the funding for
these programs is for learning English
but these teachers don't think that
stimulating enough so they want to teach
them to stand up for their human rights
however define but if it comes to a
question of being open-minded and
willing to really evaluate one's
positions I must say that I don't find
educated people such as university
people I don't find educated people any
more open-minded than people with less
education I find that in many cases that
less educated people are more willing to
listen they maybe they have less you
know hard and fast views on things so
that for a number of things they at
least perhaps they're more humble
they're prepared to listen many
University certainly people who work at
universities are people like lawyers and
people like that they do not listen at
all and you have in the same category
I'd like to think that I listen and I
like to think that I I apply some form
of analysis to the arguments that are
presented to me but I'm sure that I'm
actually quite wedded to my prejudices
and but not as badly as some and and
when I think of some of the tremendously
stupid things that university professors
say at conferences on issues that I know
something about I don't think there are
powers of critical thinking are any
better than anyone elses so I don't
think you can teach critical thinking I
think people think the way they do they
think more with their emotions and some
people have better skills at developing
arguments to support the position
reached largely emotionally and and the
idea that you can teach critical
thinking in a classroom and in
particular to beginning ESL people I
just think is a pipe dream I think that
as you know my view on language learning
is all those beginning ESL students
learners would be better off to have
stories that they can listen to and read
and listen to over and over again and
don't ask them in class you know how
what was what is the reason that you
left your little village as a refugee
and came to North America and who has
power in the society here and what is
your role and and all of this kind of
thing asking them to question their role
in society and why they can't they just
want to learn English so why don't you
make it easy for them give them classes
stories the more familiar the content is
to them the more enjoyable it is the
more likely they are to listen to it and
to learn from it yeah the more I feel
when you're learning say a language the
less you have to think the less you're
relying on logic the better the more
you're catering to the enjoyment side of
your brain the better you're gonna pick
up the language so teaching critical
thinking I just don't see it but in on
this email exchange it was all about you
know they quoted experts and they had
links to websites that were all social
activists women's issues these kinds of
things I mean if we're really serious
about critical thinking I would like to
see the teacher who would talk to say a
Somali woman or a woman from Afghanistan
and say okay now let's apply critical
thinking to Islam no I don't want to
pick on Islam it could be any religion
but if you start to apply real critical
thinking to religion first of all the
persons not gonna listen
because if they are religious they're
not interested in applying critical
thinking to their religion but there is
no religious belief that would stand up
to a genuine objective thorough sort of
critical analysis because what happens
with the critical thinking is you start
out with your belief so once you've got
the belief that's kind of the ground
floor then you build all of these
structures logical early or whatever
arguments but they're all based on this
this foundation which is you which is
your belief so in short I do not believe
you can teach critical thinking and I
think we should stay with the idea of
teaching language skills which is based
around a lot of listening and reading
and learning vocabulary and encouraging
people to express themselves on whatever
they please and that we should not try
to inculcate any kind of ideology or
even any undoubtedly very culturally
sensitive way of thinking or reasoning
on people they'll pick it up naturally
as they learn the language if they find
it that that helps them there you have